- [Instructor] During his
trip to the Vancouver Zoo,
a man was shocked when an escaped baboon
stole his ice cream.
Afraid of sustaining serious injuries,
the man consented to the baboon
that he keep the ice cream,
which wasn't his favorite flavor anyway.
I also would consent to a baboon
that was trying to eat my ice cream.
But, anyway, let's see if this
is the best way to say that.
So, the man consented to the baboon
that he keep the ice cream.
So, this is a little bit strange,
especially because the man
consented to the baboon
that he, who's he referring to?
I mean, we know, he know the ice cream,
that the baboon keep the ice cream,
but it still feels a little bit,
or is he talking about he,
the man, he, the baboon?
It feels like a little bit of
a clumsy way of saying this.
So, let's see the other
choices, how those work.
So, the man let the
baboon keep the ice cream,
which wasn't his favorite flavor anyway.
So, that one actually
doesn't seem too bad.
So, let's see, afraid of
sustaining serious injuries,
the man let the baboon keep the ice cream,
which wasn't his favorite flavor anyway.
Yeah, this seems, this seems decent.
Afraid of sustaining serious injuries,
the man granted the baboon permission
to keep the ice cream,
which wasn't his favorite flavor anyway.
This seems like a very formal thing to do
while a baboon's trying
to eat your ice cream.
Now, this is way too wordy
and just kind of weird.
Afraid of sustaining serious injuries,
the man authorized the baboon,
authorized the baboon
to keep the ice cream.
That, too, feels a little bit bureaucratic
for what's going on.
I think the man just let the
baboon keep the ice cream.
Nice and clean, to the
point, it is concise,
it is the way that most
human beings actually talk,
and it doesn't sound like something
that's happening at city hall.
So, yeah, the man let the
baboon keep the ice cream.
Even consented to the baboon that he keep,
this is very clumsy and he was consenting
for someone else to keep ice cream
is not how we talk in everyday life.